Freunde ganz kurz bevor das Video
losgeht wollte ich mich noch mal
herzlich bedanken für euren Support bei
Pasta poesia es ist wirklich unglaublich
was da passiert ist ich habe alle
Kommentare gelesen und wir waren
innerhalb von einer Stunde ausverkauft
damit hätte ich wirklich nicht gerechnet
jetzt gerade haben wir einen Vorverkauf
gestartet für den zweiten Drop wenn man
also sicher gehen will dass man beim
zweiten Drop eine Box bekommt dann ist
es gut wenn man jetzt vorbestellt
ansonsten produzieren wir auch ein
kleines Kontingent für spontane
Bestellung aber schaut jetzt mal bei
Pasta poesia.de vorbei denn in einem Tag
und ein paar Stunden wenn dieses Video
online geht ist die Vorbestellung zu
weil wir brauchen einfach die Zeit zum
Produzieren wie schmeckt das Essen in
der Business Class auf unserem Rückflug
aus Mexiko hatte ich die Möglichkeit die
Business Class von discover zu testen
und somit natürlich auch das Wichtigste
nämlich das Essen viel Spaß mit diesem
Video also normalerweise man würde jetzt
in Flieger steigen und sich zu denken
Scheiße 11 Stunden aber so denkt man
sich ja M 11
Stunden bin gespannt wie das jetzt hier
wird los geht die wilde fah eine ganz
neue Airline und auf Zeug steht noch
Euro Wings discover aber es heißt nur
noch discover und damit hat sich auch
einiges geändert das heißt wir sind
wahrscheinlich so mit vielleicht mit die
ersten die das jetzt testen auf Youtube
no joke Alter ich krieg gleich ein pris
auf zusammen könen ein hier
dur Menu wir sind natürlich fürs Essen
hier und das macht so Spaß irgendwie ich
finde so in diesem kleinen Raum in dem
man sich bewegt wird das Essen plötzlich
so wichtig und man denkt sich so ich
will einfach alles essen was hier drin
steht dann wollen wir mal oder das ist
wirklich einfach besonders jetzt geht's
los jetzt geht's in die Luft und dann
startet mit einem dreigängem Menü
dreä erstmal kleiner Drink zum starten
dann gibt eine V oh janell ja Freunde
das Flugzeug setzt sich in Bewegung
sehen wir uns
gleich so jetzt kommen wir doch zum
schönsten Part oh es wird gedeckt ich
habe noch gar nicht ins Menü geschaut
ich bin schon ganz aufgeregt so dann
schauen wir mal ins Menü hinein herzlich
willkommen wir freuen uns Sie an Bord
begrüßen zu dürfen wir freuen uns an
Bord zu Gast zu sein ich bin echt
gespannt also glaube es gibt drei Gänge
jetzt gleich zur Begrüßung das wurde uns
gerade gesagt Vorspeisen Serano Schinken
an karamellisierten fürsigpealen
marinierter grüner Spargel und mit
Amarant
überzogeneüs oh mein Gott schon Wieders
absolut C gegrillte Shrimps auf Ananas
Mango relish anchipole Mayonnaise und
marinierten Zucchinistreifen mit Humus
gefüllte zucchiniir Röllchen auf rotem
quinoaalat mit Gemüse und iioli da sehe
ich mich beim Serano Schinken in was für
einem Restaurant sind wir gerade das ist
so ein Fusion so ein crazy Fusion
Restaurant von allem das Beste gibt nehm
dir alles weg wir werden gerade Gefen
hallo was gibt es denn zur
Auswahl nochter geht sehr gut kann man
jetzt auch schon die Cocktails bestellen
dann muss ich ein Cocktail bestellen
schöner Margarita so startet doch der
Flug gut ihr müsst wissen in Mexico
haben wir fast ausschließlich Margarita
getrunkenion fruit Margarita das war so
der real deal für uns erstmal willkommen
am B fre auch
noch komm richtig Teil yes oh herrlich
was dar Vorspeise ich habe extra noch
zwei seranoschen zurückgehalten oh davon
würde ich einen nehmen dann einmal das
die Hähnchenbrust und Wolfsbarsch war
das oder searsch wunderbar Nachtisch
Käse oder eher süßer beide Desserts
einfach beide desser wir h dann genießen
wir euren Flug schön dass Ihr da seid
wenn was isteld euch dankeön so ein
netter Service WoW und nicht nur hier ne
also das ist überall das wird richtig
richtig schön wir sehen uns wenn die
Vorspeise da ist sehen wir uns gleich
wow oha das sieht ja richtig gut aus hör
mal V gegrillte fürig ist wirklich
gegrillt
uhala danke schön also Leute schauen wir
uns einmal an was was wir hier schönes
haben wir haben den gegrillten fürsig wo
man sieht der wurde wirklich gegrillt
die grillmarkierung sind auf jeden Fall
da dazu gibt es den Serano Schinken zwei
Stangen minispargel die Cashew Kerne
einen kleinen Salat etwas frisches
warmes Brot mit Butter und mein
persönliches Highlight ein kleines
Fläschchen mit Olivenöl und balsamiko
das so perfekt getrennt ist und wenn man
es ein bisschen durchschüttelt hat man
eine schön durchgemischte vinaigrett das
ist einfach cool geil und man muss sagen
wunderschön angerichtet sehr schön
angerichtet was das Crew Personal hier
aber natürlich nicht vor Ort macht ist
schon angerichtet das ist schon
angerichtet so und die packen das
lediglich aus okay ich finde aber dein
sieht fast noch ein bisschen schöner aus
was du da hast deine Vorspeise hier
schön Humus außenrum rein optisch finde
ich auch der schönere Gang einfach zu
allererst einmal möchte ich mir einfach
so ein bisschen was von diesem Brötchen
gönnen mit Butter Brötchen Butter mitten
in der Luft Dressen wir mal unseren
Salat ja das ist schon das ist schon
state of the art das auch irgendwie mega
cool einfach Öl einmal durchgeshak
drüber dann hat man noch ordentlich was
übrig um diesen Hasen hier zu machen
Öl auf Brot in so einem Flugzeug ne du
genießt einfach wirklich jeden Bissen
ich probier mal so ein gegrillten
fürsig hat noch ein schönen
Biss natürlich geiler wenn du grillst
und direkt natürlich zirano Schinken
einfach geil ne das halt genau wier
dieses Ding da wird auch nicht gespart
schon sp probi hier mal meine Zucchini
mit dem homus und Quinoa Salat die
Zucchini ist auch noch gefüllt mit Aioli
geil Aioli gleich geil sehr sehr schöner
vollmundiger Geschmack kinor leichte
Bitterkeit das schmeckt gut ja iioli
Humus geil wenn ich im ganzen jetzt eine
Note geben würde würde ich sagen deins
mit dem Serano Schenken 7hb von ze ja
meins auch 7hb von ze sch sie geben
deswegen machen wir auch mit dem
haupgang weiter darauf bin ich sehr
gespannt weißt du was man hier im
Flugzeug bräuchte was denn Pasta poesia
vielen Dank geil ist aber geil sehr
lecker boah so ein Premium Cocktail der
ist besser als im Hotel dazu so ein paar
Nüsse überhaupt nicht sprittig und so
gar nicht richtig schön sü schö süße
ja danke schön das Hauptgericht ist da
und das funktioniert bei dieser Art von
essen also bei eigentlich jeglichem
Essen das im Flugzeug serviert wird so
dass das in einer Großküche auf dem
Boden irgendwo vorgekopt wird und hier
nur noch mal gemacht wird und genau das
passiert hier auch da bis der Teller
schön heiß präsentationsweise ist das
schon gutes Stück entfernt von
Restaurantqualität muss man an dieser
Stelle wirklich sagen ich bin ja
gespannt ne also ich finde das klingt
erstmal erstmal gut ne so hähnchenbrust
in pistazienkruste ist schon nice
probieren wir einfach beide mal
oder die Soße die die dazu angegossen
haben wirklich auch sehr lecker sehr
herzhaft sehr würzig DAU dieser gelbe
Reis erinnert mich so ein bisschen an so
ein tigal weil ist auch geröstete Mandel
dabei da sind die Rosinen dabei bin
jetzt echt gespannt was du sagst weil es
schmeckt ich finde schmeckt wirklich
sehr lecker ne Hähnchenbrust super schön
zart soßeewürzig Reis auch so ein
bisschen nicht Standard einfach aber es
könnte halt wirklich viel schöner
aussehen auch leichte Schärfe was aber
geil ist und ich wünschte hät auch deins
genommen also meins muss ich sagen ich
habe ja Fisch und Polenta und so ein
bisschen Kartoffeln bisschen Gemüse die
Polenta ist hier in diesem Fall nicht so
cremig wie du sie gerne machst sondern
in so einem Taler so eine stich stich ja
genau eine stichfeste Polenta dazu habe
ich so eine leicht Grüne Soße aber
irgendwas machen wir mit diesem Hähnchen
dass das so übelst zart ist weil es ist
wirklich viel zarter als man es sich
selbst zu Hause Brett beide Gerichte und
auch die Vorspeisen bringen verschiedene
Texturen mit verschiedene Kontraste in
den Geschmäckern du hast süß salzig
herzhaft ich würd dem geschmacklich
sogar so eine a8inhb geben das schmeckt
richtig gut und das ist so eine sehb ja
aber das ist echt richtig geil ja bin
allmählich satt ich bin sehr satt sogar
ich glaube jetzt hab eine kleine
Süßigkeit oder Herzhaftigkeit und dann
können wir uns aber auch wirklich in die
Horizontale begeben das ist das worauf
ich am meisten warte die ganze Zeit ich
auch danke schön einmal Käse einmal
kuuchen Danke das Dessert ist angekommen
und es sieht sehr desserthaft aus ja du
hast Käse und Cracker bei mir ist es ein
Citrus Cheesecake geworden mit so paar
Tröpfchen noch mal angerichtet das sieht
schon so aus es könnte eigentlich nur
schmecken gehen wir rein oder gehen wir
rein probieren wir sehr schöne
Konsistenz schon halb aufgegessen bevor
ich irgendwas sage nicht der beste
Cheesecake meines Lebens aber sehr
lecker das Ding ist ich GL man muss ganz
objektiv sagen es gibt wahrscheinlich es
gibt Airlines die haben noch krasseres
essen aber nichtsdestotrotz ist das so
eine geile Erfahrung dass man es einfach
teilen muss finde ich also es ist
einfach es macht einfach Freude ich habe
drei verschiedene Käsesorten einmal ein
Frischkäse einmal so ein wie nennt man
das ein Weichkäse ja einmal einen
Hartkäse drei Gänge später bin ich sehr
gut gesättigt ich bin verdammt satt
sogar hatte einfach viel Spaß beim Essen
beim schmecken weil man schmeckt einfach
intensiv ich bin sowas von bereit mich
schlafen zu legen und dann mit einem
wunderschönen Frühstück aufzuwachen
genau das machen wir jetzt bauen wir uns
mal unser Bett
oh ich WD so gut schlafen schon klappt
sich der Sitz in ein Bett um Kissen oh
die ist richtig schön schwer und warm
gute Nacht Leute ah
guten Morgen Deutschland 11 Uhr in
Deutschland wir reden nicht mehr darüber
wie viel Uhr es in Mexiko ist weil ab
sofort gibt's nur noch die deutsche Zeit
für uns für meine Verhältnisse habe ich
so gut geschlafen wow das war wirklich
ein Segen weil beim Hinflug ich weiß
noch ich habe mir gewünscht nicht zu
existieren ich bin sehr sehr gespannt
was es jetzt zum Frühstück gibt ich
auch danke
sehr
perfekt dieser Anblick hier draußen wird
auch einfach nicht alt oh mein Gott das
ist nice diger so aufzuwachen das ist
schon einfach state of art ach herrlich
TR ger ich würde Kaffee nehmen und du
musst Espresso nehmen gibt Espresso die
haben Espressomaschine oh wow nem ich
Espresso Orangensaft und stilles
Wasser ich nur Orangensaft und stilles
Wasser gerne kein Kaffee für dich für
Kaffee Angst auf klom mus Bo das sieht
auch wirklich anders geil gerade aus ein
wunderschönes souffleet ein Müsli mit
Granola Soule bedeutet Ei das ist so
eine Special Zubereitungsform wir
servieren Ihnen ein leichtes Frühstück
griechischer Joghurt an Knuspermüsli mit
saisonalen Früchten eiersouffle mit
cheddder und tomatenkoncassé oha
garniert mit Schnittlauch Brötchen
Brioche Auswahl an Konfitüre Honig und
Nutella halt einfachön vielen vielen
Dank danke sehr vielen Dank oh das sieht
ja super aus
alri ja das sind auch noch jetzt mal die
Pancakes hier mit Apple on top als wäre
es nicht genug ich lach wirklich direkt
dieses souffle an weil ich habe in
meinem Leben wenige Male souffle
gegessen einfach so ein ja wie so ein
Kuchen aus Käse und Ei das schon
wirklich wunderschön so ein Frühstück
hier über den Wolken genießen zu können
hier wird man auf jeden Fall nicht
hungrig rausgehen Pancake probieren oder
rein in die Schüssel der ist aber FL ich
find der sieht echt vielpre der sieh
mega fluffig aus Bo zimtapfel eh eine
gottlose Kombi sehr sehr fluffy die
Frage ist was ist jetzt das Fazit neue
Airline über den Wolken Business Class
aber ganz neues Essen haben wir jetzt
nicht bekommen ich finde es war relativ
ähnlich zu unserer lufthanser experience
so von dem ganzen Aufbau her bei den
Hauptgängen der der Fisch war einfach
nicht so stark fand ich das ist ein
bisschen negativ im Hinterkopf aber der
Service der war letztes mal schon krass
aber dieses Mal also du hast wirklich je
jeden Wunsch von den Dippen abgelesen
bekommen wirklich die Leute machen das
zu was ganz Besonderem hier es ist
wirklich einfach eine tolle Erfahrung
ich habe diesmal besser verstanden warum
es bei der ganzen Sache nicht nur ums
Essen geht ja m beim letzten Flug sind
wir komplett wach geblieben jetzt wo man
wirklich geschlafen hat und so es ist
einfach ein anderes Reisen das stimmt
und das Essen ist ein kleiner Teil davon
ich finde trotzdem das hat Lust auf mehr
gemacht da draußen gibt es Airlines die
das Essen perfektionieren vielleicht
haben wir irgendwann mal die Chance eine
dieser anderen Airlines auch mal testen
wenn ihr darauf Lust habt dann schreibt
doch in die comis wir testen uns noch
durch unsere Snacks durch genießen den
Rest vom Flug aber ich denke wir sehen
uns beim nächsten Video wieder macht's
gut aus good old Germany